the people that are hurting um
significantly at the moment are the
people of the united kingdom um
how much longer can we afford to support
the battle in ukraine
well i think if we don't
uh continue to support
ukraine in this battle against putin
against this illegal invasion the price
will be much greater to pay
i am
certain of that which is why we have to
remain
uh resolute we have to coordinate
if you look at what
chancellor schultz is doing in germany
where germany is much more dependent on
russian
energy
of course other countries in europe what
is happening in the united states
this is something that we all have to to
deal with we um welcomed vladimir
zielinski to parliament had him beamed
in live the prime minister stood at the
dispatch box and actually reminded the
nation
that you know there is
uh you know more
to come in terms of what we need to do
not just the
help in terms of weapons and aid but we
need to be resolute and remember why
we're doing this there is war on our
continent you know very few people
predicted there'll be war and wars
happened in far-flung places
and our response now
our ability to stay strong of course we
have to make sure
as chancellor as a government we help
those families that need the help target
that help
tell me what that looks like well we're
at the moment
midway of spending about 37 billion yeah
but it's not enough chance of course
it's not which is what i'm gonna do the
moment i walked into the treasury on the
fifth of july i gathered my leadership
team i said one
how are we doing on delivering the help
because
it's one thing to announce it very
different to get it into people's
accounts
and there was a big focus on that but
equally importantly i said we need to
prepare options for the incoming prime
minister because if you think about the
help we're putting in here but tell me
what those options look like i'm about
to i'm about to take you through so if
you think about what we're putting in
now um the most vulnerable 8 million
households will get 1200 pounds um
everyone will get 400 pounds off their
bill
that really sort of helps with about 50
of this additional increase with the
energy price guide going up that's been
announced between october and december i
need to begin to think about what
happens in january and then in the rest
of next year you should begin to think
surely you've already been thinking
about it of course what i what i meant
is is
we have to deliver four people tell me
what it looks like
so
there's nothing off the table we're
looking at all the options
everything from the chief executive of
scottish power talking about um you know
help where uh uh you know we need to to
maybe
create a some sort of a a fund for
companies to be able to continue uh to
help uh their customers all the way
through to making sure that we target
the help to both households and small
and medium-sized businesses and probably
some larger businesses because my one of
my concerns
is
the scarring effect on the economy if
perfectly viable businesses in
hospitality and
leisure in high-energy use businesses
would actually suffer or
no longer exist because of putin's
use of energy as a as a weapon you said
that you were looking at two separate
plans depending on who was prime
minister how did they differ
well no what we
i think our responsibility is to make
sure we look at the pledges being made
by the different candidates um so uh liz
truss uh has pledged to have a
moratorium on the green levees um do you
support that that would that it
certainly is something that i think will
help uh everyone it's about 150 pounds
of additional help so we've worked up
those options i said general taxation
then wouldn't you well there is uh
hedwig
well not necessarily because actually we
have some headroom at the moment
certainly if you look at uh on the
capital side of the balance sheet we've
got some header i've got to make sure i
put all those up there are no easy
options um that's the one thing we know
because to clarify other two separate
plans depending on who's prime minister
no what we're doing is is making sure we
we
look at the pledges from both candidates
but also look at everything else that
we've been told by the energy sector so
i had the energy companies come in uh to
talk about things like liquidity in the
wholesale market and working with the
bank of england
to look at how we can provide better
liquidity in the wholesale market for
energy they tell me that would actually
help with about four to five hundred
pounds
of reduction in the energy price cap
look at
those companies that are generating wind
power and nuclear power but getting paid
at gas prices can we enter an agreement
with them for um a voluntary
contract for differences called cfd
um
at a lower price now because they're
they're not doing anything differently
in their business and they're making
very large profits it's all tinkering
though no that's not that's actually a
quite a a significant uh piece of work
but that won't be ready till next winter
exactly but we have to make sure we get
the help
the additional help from january onwards
so what's the next round of support
looking like in numbers
so
again what i'm not going to do here
it'll be irresponsible of a chancellor
to begin
to
talk numbers before a new prime minister
is involved you've been planning it
because i've got to give them the those
options sure so you know what the
numbers are
decisions no what i'm what i'm saying to
you is um it would be irresponsible i
think liz trust was right on this she's
not going to set a budget
during a campaign
she'd need to look at the detail i need
to present her those details
and of course then she will need to make
a decision what my responsibilities is
to help her hit the ground running and
that i pledge to you and your viewers we
will do how concerned are you that
people are going to
freeze from the cold this winter at home
because they can't afford to afford to
put their energy on i'm deeply concerned
i mean those people on pre-pay meters
i've we've got to make sure we that's
why i go back and say to you my my
preference is targeting the help um you
know labor have talked about sort of
universal uh uh piece of help that would
cost about
but when i ask you it you won't tell me
so when will we know no what i'm saying
to you is actually it's better to target
the help for those families that really
need it as we're doing now with the 8
million families getting 1200 pounds um
target it for smes so hospitality high
energy use sectors maybe some larger
businesses who are also
finding it very difficult when your
energy bill has gone up by three and a
half times four times it's very
difficult to be able to sustain your
business and i don't want to see that
scarring effect that we could be left
with
in the economy so all that work we will
make sure is ready for the incoming
prime minister um that's the right thing
to do and then of course in the longer
term we have an energy strategy that
ensures that we have that involves
nuclear resilience very much involves
nuclear it involves offshore wind it
involves of course tidal energy i went
to visit a company in scotland that has
actually commercialized a tidal energy
the beauty of tidal energy is actually
you can use it for base load because you
can predict the tide unlike wind and sun
uh tidal energy is is is reasonably
predictable so
lots of investment in uh offshore wind
we've seen an increase in our gas
production by about 26 percent this year
because of the policies that
quasi-cuatang uh put in place
um
by the way well that's up to the
incoming prime minister if liz trusts
the prime minister then she'll have to
decide her cabinet do you want to remain
chancellor i will serve wherever uh liz
trusts if she's our prime minister i
hope she is the prime minister decides
to even if it's health
wherever she decides you remember what i
have always said to you
you know
we we are a team we have to spend the
next 24 months delivering for the nation
um we have to make sure we help people
in this difficult time where putin is
using energy as a tool to try and divide
us both uh domestically but also divide
us understand as an alliance um i know
you've got to go let me talk to you
about sizable c quickly is that going to
be launched by the prime minister
well he's making a speech isn't it there
is ongoing negotiations with is it a
good idea with edf it is certainly a
good idea that we continue to invest in
nuclear you know it broke my heart when
i saw that i think it was a meme a video
of nick clegg saying we won't invest in
nuclear because it won't be ready until
2021.
if we'd made that investment then you
know labor divesting from nuclear under
ed miliband um uh you know
those things should have happened if
they had happened we wouldn't be
challenged in the way we are challenged
today because of of putin using energy
boris johnson and i hope uh
liz truss
will make sure that we deliver nuclear
uh both in terms of large nuclear but
then the really exciting thing is things
like the rolls-royce uh working with
constellation energy the us
energy company on the smrs these are the
the
future of nuclear uh small modular
reactors and then the
amrs beyond that which are really
exciting we've been talking about them
here
with uh our colleagues which is why
you're here yeah i get that so lots of
really important investment decisions
for the medium and longer term but not
to forget that people will need help
this winter and my my pledge to your
viewers is more help beyond the 37
billion will also be coming but we don't
know what it is yet final question
before i must let you go i understand
that um can you guarantee to my viewers
that not one of them will
find themselves in a position where they
are cut off because they cannot afford
to pay their bills
no one should be cut off because they
can account
they're because i'm working with the
companies to make sure and ngos of
course to make sure those people who
really are struggling get that help both
financially the 37 billion but the
companies themselves have already
started to write letters and emails
to ask people if they are vulnerable if
they're feeling that they can't pay that
they should contact their uh supplier
their companies
my my pledge to your viewers is that we
will deliver the 37 billion
so that 1200 pounds are the most
vulnerable 8 million households but
we'll go beyond that because we know we
need to and we need to send a message to
mr putin that this strategy is not going
to work which is why we have to target
the help to the most vulnerable to allow
us to stretch that help as far as we can
and then of course make sure that we
remain resolute as a coalition to
continue to help ukraine in their battle
they're paying with their lives with
their blood um what we have to do is
make sure
we continue to help them mr chancellor
thank you very much indeed for joining
us thank you